wichtig ist es denn für Ausländer, gut Deutsch zu können?
wichtig,
weil sie leben halt auch in Deutschland.
weil wenn wir als deutsche nach Türkei oder
in ihren Ausland fliegen,
wollen sie natürlich auch,
dass wir dann
genau dasselbe machen,
wie wie wir es möchten. ah ja, dann testen wir das mal.
ohan, bitte konjugiere das Verb schwimmen.
1.. Person Singular,
ich schwimme hm stimmt das? Daniela, wie ist es richtig?
ich schwimmen richtig.
oh Han, versuch's noch mal.
2.. Person Singular äh, du schwimmst
hm. du schwimmst. Daniela, wie heißt es richtig?
ich Schwamm. genau, ich Schwamm
tja. oh hann.
aber vielleicht die 3.. Person Singular. also erst. ach
er. sie. es schwimmt.
Daniela, und die richtige Antwort ist, er
Schwamm richtig
tja. Orhan. 1.. Person Plural äh, wir schwimmen.
wir schwimmen hm. Daniela, was sagst du?
wir sind Schwimmer. natürlich. wir sind Schwimmer.
oh Hans. 2.. Person plurreich,
oh Daniela,
wir waren Schwimmer. genau, wir waren Schwimmer.
letzte Chance. Ohren. und sie ist schwimmen.
Ohren, Ohren, Ohren.
sollte man das nicht können,
wenn man in Deutschland lebt?
ja, das ist Dramatik.
gönnt mit zur deutschen Sprache. oder
genau. also Daniela, die 3.. Person Plural von schwimmen.
sie waren Schwimmer.
sehr.